Gut, gleiches, gleiche Technik, einfach nur mit einem Richtungswechsel, das ist die sogenannte Prüfungsacht oder alle Prüfungen mit P2 bezeichnet.
Da ist es so, auch da beginnen wir auf einer Achse, wir fliegen einen komplett geschlossenen Linkskreis, also an der Prüfung wird immer mit dem Linkskreis begonnen.
Dann auf unserer Achse kommt direkt anhängender Rechtskreis, das heißt die zwei Kreise sind ein bisschen versetzt voneinander geflogen, auf einer Leitlinie und deshalb sagt man den Prüfungsacht, weil das wie so eine verschobene Acht aussieht.
Das hat nichts mit der geschriebenen Acht zu tun, es sind zwei vollständig geschlossene Kreise.
Achtet auch darauf, dass wenn ihr die Achse erreicht habt, also auf Flugzeit, der direkte Wechsel kommt.
Ihr müsst nicht geradeaus fliegen auf dieser Leitlinie und dann kommt ein Wechsel, das kostet immer Zeit.
Also sobald man Achse hat, wechseln.
Auch dieses Manöver könnt ihr mit der Bremse am Steg in der Hand fliegen oder mit der Wicklung.
Probiert beides aus und nehmt das, was euch besser gefällt.
Bremse am Steg, suchen wir beidseitig das geringste Sinken, wir checken den Luftraum, ist der Luftraum frei, kommt der Linkskreis, Gewicht links rein, rechte Hand ganz rauf.
Kurz bevor wir auf unserer Flucht sind, kommt schon das Körpergewicht, dann auf unserer Flucht die Bremse und dann kommt der direkte Wechsel, zack, in den Rechtskreis.
Dann beenden wir den Rechtskreis fast vollständig, kurz bevor wir auf unserer Achse sind, geht der Körper in die neutrale Sitzposition und gleichzeitig aber entspannt, also zieht die Außenbremse immer langsam, gefühlvoll, kommt dann die Außenbremse,
sodass wir beidseitig angebremst sind.
Auch da ist erst einmal wichtig, nicht die Zeit, sondern einfach Flucht.
Flucht und das gleiche gilt eben auch für den Doppelkreis.
Flucht ist erst einmal wichtig, Orientierung im Raum, Einstellen der Querlage, Körperverlagerung und so weiter.
Die Zeit kommt dann später.
Je mehr wir das Ganze trainiert haben, umso wohler fühlen wir uns dann, wenn die Querlage mal ein bisschen mehr eingestellt wird.
Und so können wir uns dann auch wieder einstellen.
Und so können wir uns dann immer mehr auf diese Zeit.
Wenn ihr das Ganze mit halber Wicklung fliegt, achtet einfach darauf, dass ihr nicht zu viel bremst.
Wir haben einen kürzeren Steuerweg, das heißt, geringste Sinken suchen.
Zack, Gewichtsverlagerung, Querlage einstellen, dann den Kreisfast ganz beenden.
Zack, Gewicht neutral und der direkte Wechsel in den Rechtskreis rüber.
Und sobald der Rechtskreisfast komplett geschlossen ist, gehen wir in die neutrale Sitzposition.
Zack, nehmen die Außenbremse mit, sodass wir wieder angebremst herauskommen.
Sobald wir das haben, dürfen wir dann die Bremse auch wieder vollständig freien.
Bei der Acht passiert das oft, dass man den ersten Kreis ziemlich zügig einleitet.
Dann kommt der Wechsel und man macht mehrheitlich fast den Wingover auf diese Seite und verhungert dann so nach dem ersten Input.
Zack, Gewichtsverlagerung.
Das bedeutet darauf, dass ihr direkt beim Wechsel auch mit der Außenbremse arbeitet.
Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt hier reingehe, zack, kurz bevor ich auf meiner Flucht bin, kommt die Außenhand mit dem Gewicht harmonisch,
sodass ich eigentlich auf meiner Achse beidseitig gebremst bin und dann kommt der harmonische direkte Wechsel.
Okay, und auch da wieder immer dran denken, Außenbremse.
Das Außenbremsen ist ein wichtiges Element beim Gleitschirmfliegen.
Wenn wir in der Spirale enden beispielsweise oder einfach beim Doppelkreis in einer sehr starken Querlage,
werden wir nie die Innenhand freigeben, sondern wir ziehen immer die Außenbremse so weit nach unten, bis wir gerade rauskommen aus dem Ganzen.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Element und darum geht es.
Für das Manöver 8 wird eine vorgegebene Fluggachse eingenommen.
Durch dosiertes Ziehen der linken Steuerleine wird ein Linkskreis geflogen, bis der Schirm wieder auf der ursprünglichen Fluggachse ist.
Mit dosiertem Ziehen der rechten Steuerleine wird anschließend ein Rechtskreis geflogen, bis der Schirm wieder auf der ursprünglichen Fluggachse ist.
Durch dosiertes Anbremsen werden nachfolgende Roll- und Nickbewegungen abgefangen und der Schirm stabilisiert.
Vorsicht! Beim Richtungswechsel können zu starkes Ziehen der Steuerleine oder falsches Timing zu einem einseitigen Strömungsabriss führen.
Die Zeitdauer für das Manöver beträgt maximal 25 Sekunden.
Wichtig!
Die Zeitmessung stoppt erst, wenn der Schirm stabil auf der ursprünglichen Fluggachse fliegt.